well if I grew up in America and I grew
up in let's say Taiwan because Taiwan's
a great example because it you know it's
right there and you have China Hong Kong
and there's a difference between Hong
Kong and Mainland China which people
don't consider now is everything that
goes on in mainland China and Hong Kong
should it be equal well no because
because Hong Kong has had a very very
different socialization and everything
going on in Hong Kong then mainly in
China for about you know last hundreds
of years you know what I mean mm-hmm
so social justice flattening between
mainland China and Hong Kong wouldn't be
fair if it was equalized now if you took
the same things in mainland China
applied in Hong Kong
try to apply them here in America in the
United States would it be all the same
social justice if we can artificially
change it because we say all social
justice is equal across the entire world
well it's not because you have so many
different factors in so many things
yes the same thing as term limits for
America when we start trying to
artificially force a congressional
district to not have a certain Congress
person because they've been in here for
30 or 40 years no I don't like some of
them there's a Congress person has been
in there for like freaking 40 years I
can't stand a guy cuz I think he forgot
about his ditch his district he's from
and he goes and all those big huge
things and forgets about his district
constantly and I really think he should
start looking at the district more
because whatever one's brought him in
but he's doing a lot of really great
things at a national scale but come on
dude clean up that River and take care
of that and take care of people in your
district now do we need to force a
tournament on a guy no it needs to bring
attention to the fact that he's
forgetting about the people in his
district and maybe have them vote a
little differently but if he gets voted
in again then rock on man you got voted
again so you made it past that
tournament called voting right so
there's a lot of things you can think
about different ways and when it comes
to social justice
I think it's social justice making it
equal across
certain spectrums of society certain
spectrums of religion certain spectrums
of environmental conditions you know
it's it's different it's different in
New York City than it is where I live in
upstate New York I live like six hours
in New York City
in New York State now if you get a DUI
in New York City and they take away your
driver's license for six months they're
like yeah whatever big deal I don't care
because he have busses on every block
they have subways
they have movers they have a thousand
Ebers that they're freaking back and
call but if you leave while I do in a
town of 200 and the closest the closest
Walmart is a 40-minute drive the closest
grocery store is like well we have one
dollar store right there and it's a good
dollars for a thanks a lot but that's 20
minutes away so if I have no driver's
license and if I drove and it took me 20
minutes to drive so the closest place
for me to buy toilet paper which is a
big hype now and covet but if you drive
20 minutes to get a roll of toilet paper
if I have no license how long does it
take me to walk and you took away my
license for six months it's so different
between New York City that I have a
thousand uber drivers I have taxis
everywhere
I have subway and our buses I have
transportation you know I have a million
ways to travel but if I'm out here where
I'm living if I have no driver's license
I have to walk everywhere or got a call
up on my friends constantly it's not
fair
yeah it's definitely not a level playing
field when it comes to the differences
between the states we live in in
different countries and you know New
York State is the worst because New York
City is as hub of metropolitan
everything but if you drive an hour out
of New York City you're you're in you're
you're different and you're applying all
the laws Governor Cuomo applies all the
laws that make great sense in New York
City but it totally like it hampers and
is punishing to everyone that lives an
hour outside of New York City it's a
punishment it's it's it's it's like
what's that
unusual punishment for you to make me do
the New York City DUI laws when I'm here
south of Buffalo on five hours from six
hours from New York City doesn't make
sense it's cruel and unusual punishment
social justice somebody should be
standing up for me
the ACLU they're taking away my civil
rights my civil liberties because I
can't drive so I can't work I can't even
get a brutal toilet paper without
walking for four hours to four hour walk
to go get a toilet paper mm-hmm
that's cool punch man and you're gonna
do those same laws why doesn't the ACLU
pick up that case you can't apply the
urban laws for the DUI taking away my
driver's license I know somebody who's
had her driver's license taken away for
two years and it's hampered work it's
like failing it loses house loses
everything is he can't drive yeah the
system's definitely not set up for you
to win no you can win in the city but
outside of the city the same laws they
just don't work and they have to
consider that so why can't they make the
laws like a per capita basis so if you
live in an area we're per capita or how
many people live in that area if I live
in a town of 200 and they closed the
city away from me is a town of 900
that's a city it's huge it's a
metropolis and I only have 900 people I
have to drive two and a half hours away
to get to a city of 10,000 or more and
you can apply in New York City laws to
me dude come on
yeah cruel and unusual punishment why
doesn't a lawyer pick up that case
that's a class-action lawsuit against
the state of New York
mmm cuz you love New York City you're
making fuku money off New York City the
alligator I will it's all about money
right it's crazy
Allegheny County has across the entire
state
per capita percentage of duis is the
highest in Allegheny County per capita
it's crazy because we're all lose our
job and you get another one you don't
want to do y'all drinking the highest
unemployment rate
is Allegheny County so the highest DUI
the highest unemployment the highest
taxes on one County it's a county where
there's no city that's more bigger than
frickin a thousand people the biggest
city gee tire counties like this the
metropolis of a thousand people they
live in a freaking 20 mile square it's
like if you studied it if New York
somebody would take a look at this if
you compare that one County to like
Queens or kings or the Bronx or Brooklyn
dude there are millions of people in one
County the products compared to
Allegheny County millions of people
living in one square mile compared to we
have frickin thousand square miles with
you know forty thousand people total but
we have the most duis most unemployment
and the highest freakin taxes out of all
of New York State they're punishing us
it's cruel and unusual punishment to
live this how close is this the same
count three and you think things are the
cards are stacked up for everyone in
Allegheny County to fail the cards are
stacked up to make us all get duis and
unemployed Sydnor and then we start
driving because I had to drive then I
get pulled over again well your drivers
are suspended you have one to you I well
now you can have a driver's license for
five years some 80 even worse so now I'm
unemployed with no license for five
years no buses no uber no nothing how do
I get around I get a hike 20 miles to
get a roll of toilet paper would you
expect from us you're gonna put us on
welfare
you're gonna put us on food stamps
you're gonna make us in the freakin
thievin drug in drinking DUI unemployed
because there's nothing for us to do and
we can't get out you can't dig yourself
out of that hole once you get so deep
mm-hmm no totally Allegheny County
should be a study in New York State's
ability to punish a whole population of
people that's what they did
governor como
I Love New York City heats Allegheny
County he hates us and with highest at
County in New York State how far is that
county from where you were raised
it's the same County same exact County
so you're 15 minutes yeah 15 well if you
drive really fast yeah yeah if you drive
no speed limit it's about eight to
twenty three minutes so another subject
same County
how how would you say that your
upbringing and your childhood directed
your the rest of your life how much of
your childhood had an effect on your
decision to eventually join the Navy
SEALs and do was it 15 combat
deployments or 14 combat deployments was
13 deployments 13 saying that you saying
that's not a lot no oh I would shut it
down more I don't feel like I did enough
really how many people do you know that
I've done that many combat deployments a
lot okay three for three or four I don't
know but it's I don't know I don't know
I mean I never try to count okay it's
not it's not a number that you count
like look at but I still don't think I
did enough
I'd still I was still wish I could do
some more but I gear up I grew up in
rural it was very rural very
self-sufficient we had farm animals so
you always had to get water it feed and
take care of them always like doing
crops or taking care of down throwing
hay bales in grade school I was throwing
hay bales so you've learned how to be
like um seems like you were always very
very hands-on rugged individualism I'm a
guy rugby handsome it was like MacGyver
you know I'm a guy average [ __ ] out of
it
so I was in I was going to lows the
other day so I was going to lows the
other day and they made this new rule
for New York City it doesn't it should
apply that but is New York State wide
rule that Governor Cuomo came out
at this date time everyone in public has
to have a mask on because basically if
you live in New York City you're living
on top of another thousand people if you
walk into any 7-eleven New York City
just give me a hundred people in that
store now if you walk into a 7-eleven
where I live there's one person in there
every 20 minutes so your social distance
and where I live is natural you know
what I mean mm-hmm so I'm walking into
the Lowe's and there's somebody's
standing guard and I got a big signs in
there that New York state law everyone
must have one of those masks on in order
to answer any store the New York State
wide law yeah it makes sense in New York
City but out here in the entire law
there's only like four people so it's
not very hard to keep 20 feet away from
every person in a freaking store
[Laughter]